I'm so happy to be here I am so happy
you're here as well and also your colors
are this is you're like a you like glow
as you walk in this is beautiful I have
to tell you this and I think some people
may or may not know this but when you
come on your show I try to make make it
a look that I think you would appreciate
okay reflects the experience that is
very kind that is very kind yeah if you
dress poorly I'm gonna be like get out
get out of here but anyway are you
excited like with your kids for like the
holidays coming up my kids love
decorating and doing all the stuff oh my
gosh they're crazy about it yeah my
daughter well her she's born in she's
born December 15th so it's just a
month-long party I always feel sorry for
December birthdays yeah as of now Jesus
totally trumps you every time
well she just thinks of it as like
starting December 1st it's just like
preparation for Christmas and her
birthday it's just party months right
now she just like loves it yeah and
Optimist I like it and then well you've
got something else to look forward to so
I hear the next year is Walk of Fame
you're getting your Walk of Fame yes
[Applause]
I literally just had I just did my and I
and you know what I'm going to tell you
the weirdest thing about it it's awesome
all of it is awesome but I have never in
20 years had everyone from every part of
my career under one umbrella like one
tent for one thing it's the first time
that's ever happened so you're gonna
look out and see people that sounds very
stressful you know what it wasn't it
wasn't no I tend to not keep those
people around that's smart that's right
yeah I just and like so I first of all I
don't know who to invite I'm like am I
gonna fill the number of seats because
I'm like kind of a homebody second of
all like there's so much there's like do
you put your hands in the is that Justin
that's that's grommins that's Grandma's
where they do that that's a different
thing it's right there like where the
stars are but it's it's a I learned this
wait there's two different ways exactly
that we commemorate famous people
exactly we come up with them I didn't
know this either and so whenever it was
happened I was like do I have to do my
hands or something like no it's gromin
so it's like I'm here getting like all
like excited to do that photo or oh you
do the photo where you're on the ground
with the star yeah which try and look
attractive in that environment like I I
literally
I was like I guess approved like they're
horrible but like it's just like the
most awkward you have to lay down
sideways on the dirty Street yeah it's
not great if that look isn't great but
I'm sure you'll pull it off yeah I
didn't and I just leaned into humor
um but but when your office co-stars be
there well people that you've been
working with are you you're right yeah
I'll invite them they're pretty busy I
think there's a couple that'll
definitely definitely come yeah I think
it'll be fun I I'm one of these people I
don't like to ever I mean I I try to but
I have trouble reflecting on success
because I'm superstitious and I feel
like we spend too much time thinking
about like oh you did a great job or you
should commemorate this that something
bad is gonna happen it's like I don't
know I'm just like one of those people
so sometimes big life like Milestones
like I didn't do a baby shower I didn't
do any of that stuff because I was like
I don't want to jinx up I've just always
been this way like it's just I'm so
awesome so this this like well listen
that's the healthy way to be I didn't
actually want a baby shower because I
hated pregnancy and I just wanted all
humans to get away from me but like but
most time I think it's I think try and
think of it though it's also kind of
cool to go
I I think because in my career I don't
know if you feel the same you forget
things that happen yeah like you forget
because you didn't take the time to have
that moment you didn't take the time to
have that to commemorate it commemorate
it yeah yeah so I don't know but also to
my kids no to my kids I can be like see
I'm like a big deal don't give me any
crap no I'm telling you my six and eight
year old were there and they were like
they literally lean over to my mom and
my sister I can't remember which one it
was and they're like why is everybody
like yelling like for my mom like they
were like they just thought it was so
weird yeah it's kind of it's kind of
cool to see you're like yeah this is
Mommy works hard yeah it's kind of nice
to be like that's right yeah I know it's
true it's nice but anyway you posted
this photo recently so I want to I want
to show this
like this is Throwback yeah it is like
is this one y'all first kind of started
yeah so when we first did the office I
mean this is so sweet the first two
seasons of The Office whenever it aired
we would go over to someone's house and
we'd like watch the show together which
is something so cool no people don't do
that and I thought that was normal but
like Steve was like the star of the show
and like you can tell by the snacks like
this is not a fancy party yeah and
Angela these are my people with that
snack tray I'm like cool like just like
pretzel sticks and everything Angela we
just took turns throwing it and there
wasn't this idea of like oh my house
isn't fancy enough because it was
Hollywood like we felt so separate yeah
well the show is not that glamorous or
anything when you watch it but I just
when I saw it I first of all was like
wow that's so fun that we did that and
second of all I was like Steve Carell is
so hot
I feel like Lee doesn't get enough
credit for being like kind of a Babe I'm
Gonna own this right now so I have
always thought he was cute right but he
came here and it was for our first it
was for the First Premiere yeah because
he did the Kelly Clarkson this dude
hanging out backstage he had like a like
a long like trench coat like thing he
had all this salt and pepper facial hair
I was like oh okay I was
what the hell is happening right now
literally the buzz the entire day was
how hot is Steve crap oh yeah I was like
I was like what anyway so I'm with you
on that I love though that that was your
first experience you're saying like in a
big way like of experiencing Hollywood
because it what because we're I think we
all are this you know and then you know
your career happens and you get to like
maybe elevate your snacks
exactly but sometimes you don't want to
and you just want to go back to the
pretzel sticks because it's easier yeah
you're from Boston but now it looks
pretty evident that you're an LA Lakers
fan I'm just gonna show these photos you
know we're really into the game you like
going to games I love going to the games
and you know for my from my dad you know
we grew up in Boston he loved basketball
he's a big sports fan and to be able to
take him to the game like it's such a
big deal I'm doing a show right now but
the Lakers but Jeannie Buss who owns
Lakers she's an incredible woman we've
had her in here yeah she's incredible so
it's so this is research I guess you
could say is like going to these games
and it's it's amazing and I was just
there and look Ron is there obviously
and it's such a great opportunity to
just take these like creepy photos of
him
you know why can't they just
[Laughter]
they'd just be like on the bench and I'm
just like taking pics of it because he's
just so famous I mean it's actually I
mean worldwide he's so famous but just
like it's LeBron like he's just amazing
so that's what I I pictured you at the
game the whole time taking shots yeah
did you see the game you know honestly
like I was I had to like my dad was like
Hey we're here to see the game this is a
game yeah but it's like it is it is
truly it is truly amazing and he's like
you know so he's like one of my most
favorite people alive yeah man great
player yeah yeah I love going to games
like for the mingling and the food
um yeah and the game
um you know what my fear is about that
order is like I'm so worried that when
the camera if you have good seats if the
camera catches you and you're just like
eating a hamburger and then the player
falls on you or something I I just like
I just want to say dainty so I just like
sip water or whatever I think just early
on like yeah I know I've had like the
worst photos of me taking like in a
bathing suit like going down on like a
big dog like I've had the worst photos
like like a wave coming up and I'm not
like Heidi Klum it's just like and it's
like you know it's so comedic that I
just lean in and don't care I feel like
most of my life is avoiding becoming a
meme I am 100 I don't care
meme it up
I don't care I'm gonna live my life I'm
gonna have the hot dog
um did LeBron ever notice you taking
pictures because you're really
recognizable no so one time I went to a
game and he I I was sitting next to
Chipotle I didn't know and he came down
and he waved and I assumed like clearly
that he's waving at somebody else like
why would he be waving at me and then I
looked at the two guys to see like who
LeBron's friends were and they were like
we don't know him and I was like I think
LeBron was waving at me maybe he's a big
The Mindy Project fan he never knew wait
yeah so he could send me a little wave
and you didn't wave back no because they
didn't know it was me so now he probably
thinks I'm unfriended he thinks you're
snob big time to him so now he'll know
because yeah because we're gonna get
this message out I just you know she
would have waved LeBron she would have
waited I would have way back I didn't
want to be you know the worst feeling is
when someone waves and you're like hey
and they're like we don't care about you
it was the person next to you I didn't
want to be that guy yeah I've been that
person a lot too I feel like I'm a lot
of what you don't want to be
you should hang out with me you feel
really good about yourself I know I will
cover the ground of all the other things
and I won't care how do you think
that like in the public I think it's
happening or whatever how do you think
that's effective being a mom because I
feel like it it changed my perspective
on things yeah I was already kind of
nonchalant about a lot of Industry
things but I think it just kind of
changed my perspective even on my
relationships with people did that did
that change for you yeah you know I
think it's the thing with my kids is
that I'm really private about them you
know I it's hard because I love them so
much and I talk about them so much but I
don't put them on social media yeah but
I don't judge people who do because like
every time they do anything cute I want
to put them on there but I'm also like
they're not really consenting to it so
yeah but in terms of just like the
projects I do I do want to do shows
about young women who are not perfect
but who like learn to accept themselves
you know and who don't look like the
kind of women we've seen on TV before
you know and it doesn't seem like that
profound or anything but it just I
didn't have that growing up and it would
be nice if it was on TV for my daughter
for our kids and again I'm forgetting
about my son who also needs good TV yeah
but he he'll be fine he's fine he'll be
fine no I will say so sex lives of
college girls on HBO and your Netflix
show never have ever are both young
women kind of finding themselves right
yeah so this is a thing that is super
important to you because it's a
narrative you like yeah yeah I mean I
think the thing is is I want to make
shows like first and foremost that like
make you laugh and entertain I feel like
life is well done accomplished thank you
I want to go home and just turn on the
TV and be like entertained I don't
always need to see serial murderers and
like all that kind of stuff and I just
feel like I want to make something
that's funny if they can be funny and
they look a little different than what
people are used to like even better yeah
I don't want to like preach it people
and you know try to make you know teach
people lessons and make them feel bad
about themselves I just want them to see
different perspectives so that's what
I'm trying to do I love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]